alors est ce que tu t'es déjà confessé
toi non jamais donc c'est la première
fois que tu vas te confessé première et
devient mon petit jean marie bigard
messieurs
mais tu favorable à la peine de mort
n'ont jamais des queues et qui est mort
jeudi n'ont qu il faut jamais télé qui
se soigne une bête ni encore moins un
homme même pour les assassins d'enfants
même pour la safa d'enfants bien sûr il
fallait il faudra bien lui pardonner il
ya en rien d'autre qui marchera mieux
contre la haine quel amour tu crois en
dieu oui tu médites oui tu es plus
tourné vers les philosophies orientales
que oui plus totale
plutôt oui l'hindouisme tout ça et ça ça
me branche lui est ce que ces sondes et
des religions qui te quitte même pas des
religions n'ayant ma faim disant que
c'était sur des pratiques qui te laisse
en liberté complète du jour n'est pas
obligé d de t'ouvrir de vide et on sent
toute ta vie et de tout donner ce que tu
as sur le dos pour un jour aller dans un
pseudo paradis c'est pas ça le truc moi
ça me correspond mieux les gilets le fil
orientale parce qu'elle nous laisse en
liberté tue en contact avec des gourous
d'eiffage luis rencontre actuellement
mais qu'attend mais dit on a oui on a
un gourou et voilà que c'est ces âmes
située sur google c'est un vrai gourou
c'est une
c'est une communication avec dieu steve
mathieu c'est comme une douche tu vois
votre maître dessous c'est quelqu'un qui
a un qui n'a qui n'a plus d'ego et quand
une fois battu c'est que c'est un vrai